[Musica]
sono una giornalista lavoro per rainews
che è il canale della rai che va in onda
24 ore su 24 per lavoro ascolto le
storie degli altri e poi le racconto
sono tanti anni che faccio la
giornalista però è negli ultimi che
farlo mi ha cambiato la vita ed è quello
che vorrei provare a raccontarvi oggi
faccio una premessa sono cresciuta
principalmente in italia è da sempre mi
sento fare questa domanda di dove sei
anzi la domanda di solito è di dove sei
veramente che voi vuol dire non mi
sembra che tu debba stare qui adesso lo
dovresti spiegare così io me ne faccio
una ragione
questa ovviamente è una domanda che
viene fatta a tantissime persone non
succede solo a me però per tanto tempo
mi ha fatto credere di essere un po
fuori posto oppure di non avere un posto
nel mondo
e così vorrei arrivare al tema di questa
giornata che l'ascolto perché io penso
che l'ascolto abbia molto a che fare con
il trovare il proprio posto nel mondo
nel senso che quando qualcuno ti ascolta
chi riconosce che tu hai qualcosa da
dire qualcosa di importante e questo ti
dà un posto nel mondo
diciamo però all'epoca quando accendo la
televisione o guardavo i politici il
governo i professori gli allenatori le
ballerine non trovavo mai storie simili
alla mia visibile al mio e lo stesso
anche nei libri nei romanzi nei racconti
sono sempre stata una lettrice
appassionata
di storia di questo tipo non trovavo
quasi niente
c'era il silenzio erano gli anni 90
adesso la situazione è migliorata sono
stati fatti dei passi avanti ma
decisamente non abbastanza
diciamo però che per una parte di questa
mia vita mi sono sentita un po ai
margini finché poi mi sono ritrovata a
lavorare per la rai dopo un concorso
quindi decisamente non più ai margini
molto mainstream al centro di una
macchina gigantesca dove ho dovuto
imparare a trovare la mia strada il mio
modo di raccontare di fare la
giornalista è stato un percorso come per
tutti di prove ed errori di domande e di
risposte c'è stato però un momento in
cui in un ufficio con il quale non aveva
una grande dimestichezza
buongiorno incontrato un capo che non
conoscevo per nulla
e durante la nostra conversazione mi è
sembrato per la prima volta di guardarmi
allo specchio lavorativamente mi è
sembrato che tante tessere sparse
diventassero improvvisamente un mosaico
e questo penso che abbia molto a che
fare col fatto che mi è sembrato che
questa persona mi ascoltasse anche e
soprattutto quando stavo zitta
e mi sono resa conto che questa mia non
appartenenza univoca riconosciuta era
stata una fragilità e lo era per opera
anche la mia unicità e soprattutto era
la porta attraverso la quale passava il
mio modo di essere giornalista cioè io
ho capito che volevo liberare certe
storie dal silenzio il silenzio che
avevano a volte dai media
ecco liberare le storie dal silenzio una
frase in cui mi rispecchio molto e se
fossi un po più giovane o se fossi il
tipo mela stare anche tatuata non ho
fatto per ora vorrei spiegare perché c'è
qui tutto quello che vorrei dire oggi
liberare perché il silenzio quando ti
viene imposto è come se fosse una gabbia
ti ci trovi dentro imprigionato e ti
sembra che quell angolo buio sia l'unico
posto che ti meriti essere costretti al
silenzio vuol dire non avere
cittadinanza nel mondo reale o
nell'immaginario ed è molto difficile
uscire da soli da questa situazione e
soprattutto perché se nessuno ti ascolta
ad un certo punto può succedere che
tutti convinca che quello che è da dire
effettivamente non conta niente
e poi ci sono le storie dicevo che ho
imparato che volevo raccontare le storie
degli altri volevo chiedere alle persone
di raccontarmi un loro
dolore un passaggio importante della
loro vita un sogno successo una vita
intera una battaglia chiedevo tante cose
quindi e ho capito che per ascoltarle
davvero dovevo prima imparare a vivere
bene dentro la mia di storia ed è per
questo che vela vorrei raccontare oggi
dicevo prima del posto nel mondo ecco
nella mia storia ce ne sono tanti sono
cresciute in italia vivo in italia la
mia una parte italiana diciamo è legata
a mia madre ma un'altra parte l'altra
metà prosegue la storia di mio padre
la nostra famiglia è originaria di goa
in india e poi
all'inizio del novecento si è spostata a
nairobi in kenya è questa questa casa
per noi per la nostra famiglia è un po
il centro il fulcro di tutta la nostra
storia un punto d'inizio ed è un punto
di arrivo ma è anche un luogo che ci
portiamo tutti nel cuore perché non
esiste più
ebbene di questa casa della nostra
storia con i miei familiari parliamo
moltissimo come ce la portiamo dietro
nella nostra vita reale nei vari paesi
in cui viviamo e questa è una storia
poco nota è una storia però che appunto
ritorna nelle nostre conversazioni per
preparare questo discorso
ne ho richiamate tante alla memoria che
ho fatto con i miei parenti quest'estate
in kenya portorico ho parlato per tante
ore al telefono con uno dei fratelli di
mio padre che per primo ha ricostruito
il nostro albero genealogico e mi ha
fatto capire quanto sia faticoso
ripercorrere una storia la propria
storia ma anche quanto sia bello e
importante
diceva una storia che non c'è sui libri
di storia legata al colonialismo è un po
una terra di mezzo
riguarda migliaia di persone che in una
certa epoca si è spostata dall'india al
kenya e poi è tutta l'east africa per
definire questa comunità di persone c'è
una parola i suoi chili che quindi
quindi significa letteralmente una
persona originaria dell'india ed è una
parola che mi porta in kenya ma mi fa
anche tanto pensare alla diaspora al
lavoro enorme che fa per non fare
dimenticare questa storia mughini però è
anche una parola che io non avrei mai
usato quando non pensavo di avere un
posto nel mondo nell'epoca diciamo
scuole medie
immaginate di raccontare un pezzo della
nostra storia con una parola
intraducibile una lingua che non conosce
quasi nessuno che si parla in un paese
che ne sposi nessuno sa mettere sulla
mappa avrei scelto all'epoca il silenzio
è infatti l'ho fatto
e così veniamo alla terza parte della
frase il silenzio liberare le storie dal
silenzio vuol dire ascoltarle un ascolto
che un po come un viaggio è un tipo di
ascolto questo che ti fa perdere
l'equilibrio anche tutte un bel po di
certezze che hai ti svuota perché cerchi
di lasciare da parte le tue opinioni
tuoi pregiudizi ma ti nutre perché ti
mette di fronte all'altro e alla sua
vita
è un po una magia e se dovessi però
raccontarlo è come se l'intervistato ed
io avessimo in mano entrambi un filo un
filo che nelle norme diversità ci unisce
poi quello che succede in pratica che
noi ci incontriamo in un luogo che può
essere milano o roma doma che town ham
ci costruiamo la nostra terra di mezzo e
questa persona mi affida la sua storia e
io la trasforma in un racconto che il di
somma supera il secondo livello del
silenzio diventa un servizio per il
telegiornale un reportage questa storia
poi è libera di andare da sola di
arrivare al pubblico tra tra tutti noi
dicevo che per tanto tempo non ho visto
delle storie dei visi simile al mio in
televisione
adesso ci lavora e cerco di farne buon
uso alcune volte mi riesce bene altre
meno diciamo che ci provo e vorrei
raccontarvi alcune delle storie appunto
che trovo molto importanti che ci
possano portare un messaggio per la
nostra vita di tutti i giorni
inizierei con la storia di chi chi chi
chi williams vive in california e la
vedremo tra pochissimo è stata per tanti
anni senza tetto ha vissuto in macchina
con il figlio piccolo poi ha trovato un
lavoro iniziato a vivere in una casa ma
non ha dimenticato quella parte della
sua vita eccola qui kiki e ha iniziato a
cucinare i pasti per i senzatetto ogni
weekend le all'alba prepara lasagne
pollo riso cibo caldo lo porta a queste
persone in california ed allora un
momento di speranza di nutrimento di
ritrovamento della dignità
in quel momento sa quanto sia importante
per loro non vergognarsi della loro
condizione si ricorda benissimo di
com'era essere appunto una ragazza madre
che viveva che viveva in auto il filo
che la mia messo in mano e questo quante
volte delle parti di noi stessi di cui
ci vergogniamo cerchiamo di non fare
sapere niente agli altri invece lei ha
saputo superare questa paura e alza
trasformato la sua esperienza in a
generosità vorrei che fosse chiaro che
tutte le persone come chicchi per
esempio sanno e se vogliono possono
raccontare la loro storia lei per
esempio lo fa per raccogliere fondi per
questo progetto
io oggi però vi vorrei solo raccontare
il mio modo di rapportarmi alle storie
che racconto come giornalista
un'altra storia a cui tengo molto arriva
da da nairobi e la storia di douglas i
dialoghi che ho incontrato quest'estate
nel memoriale che ricorda le vittime del
doppio attentato che c'è stato nel 98
alle ambasciate americane del cane della
tanzania da classi diario rimasto cieco
in quella esplosione e quando abbiamo
raccontato la sua storia era agosto era
quando i talebani hanno preso kabul e
gli americani che stavano lasciando la
pianista ci ha ringraziato ci ha detto
grazie per ricordare la nostra storia
perché spero che la memoria sia un passo
verso la giustizia quello che è successo
è che i cittadini americani
i sopravvissuti e familiari delle
vittime i dipendenti delle ambasciate
hanno ricevuto la compensazione
mentre la maggioranza dei cittadini del
cane della tanzania come lui non hanno
ricevuto mai niente anzi sono dovuti
pagare da soli le cure mediche in quel
caso il filo a me l'ha dato lui stesso
in mano e mi ha detto pensa quante volte
noi pensiamo di non avere diritti
solamente perché chi ha il potere le
istituzioni ci dicono che quei diritti
non ce li abbiamo
e poi ancora un'altra storia che che vi
vorrei raccontare oggi ci porta
all'epoca della colonia italiana in
somalia ed è una storia dicevo di posto
nel mondo perché le persone protagonisti
di questa storia un posto nel mondo non
ce l'hanno mai avuto perché è stato loro
negato
sono degli uomini adulti si chiamano
gianni mari antonio murate mauro caruso
sono nati in somalia sappiamo che la
somma gli è stata una colonia italiana
da madre somala e padre italiano
all'epoca poi stessi padri tornavano in
italia e dimenticavano le famiglie che
avevano la è bene loro sono cresciuti in
collegi italiani e somalia dove sono
stati di fatto mutilati di metà della
loro storia perché non hanno avuto un
rapporto quotidiano con la madre hanno
dovuto dimenticare la lingua somala e la
parte somala delle loro tradizioni e
nonostante questo
quando sono venuti in italia nessuno li
ha riconosciuti come italiani non è
stato dato loro un posto nel mondo
questa è una storia che fare con il
colonialismo con il fatto che la loro
pelle non sia bianca con quella
in senso di inadeguatezza che ci
portiamo dentro quando cielo instillano
fin da quando siamo piccoli
se ci pensate il filo può essere che se
togliamo i riferimenti temporali sono
tante storie simili a questa
che nell'italia di oggi
l'ultima storia che vi vorrei raccontare
oggi arriva dal sud africa questa che
vedete è la reverenda rene august po
incontrate a un mesetto fa in occasione
dei funerali desmon tutu dove sono stata
per per lavoro e volevo che lei mi
raccontasse che cosa voleva dire per
l'arcivescovo combattere a parte e poi
costruire il nuovo sudafrica insieme a
nelson mandela e lei mi ha ricordato che
cosa è stato la partenza cioè quella
regime razzista che alle persone
nereo colored come era classificata lei
ha tolto per legge tutto ha tolto i
diritti ha tolto la dignità ha tolto
l'istruzione ha tolto anche il futuro
lei stessa mi ha spiegato che chi
all'epoca solo perché aveva una pelle
non bianca ha avuto un istruzione di
cattiva qualità o scarsa ancora oggi
magari accesso dei lavori di qualità
inferiore questo significa che può
offrire meno ai loro figli vuol dire che
la partita si è costruito la possibilità
di sopravvivere alla sua esistenza
legale e ci sono persone come lei
tantissime che non stanno facendo altro
da decenni che cercare di spezzare
questo circuito anche qui questo è una
storia sudafricana però il filo è
abbastanza facile da ritrovare se
pensiamo a quanti paesi hanno un coro
posti dorme ancora discriminatorie e
bene però tornando all'ascolto lei mi ha
raccontato tutto questo sedute su una
panchina dove c'era scritto white soling
riservate ai bianchi e mi ha detto lo
sai che all'epoca durante l'apartheid
nessuna di noi due avrebbe potuto
sedersi qui perché ci avrebbero cacciato
insultate arrestate multate addirittura
picchiate perché quella all'epoca era la
legge
è bene penso che reneo questo avrebbe
tanto da dirci oggi sull'ascolto anche
come forma di lotta e l'ultima storia
che vi racconto oggi ce ne sono
veramente mille che avrei voluto
raccontarvi mi sono fatta però la
promessa di dare voce di liberare tante
altre storie dal silenzio perché ci sono
così migliaia di persone che non sono
rappresentate adeguatamente un acqui
storia viene ingiustamente messa da
parte e non raccontata le cause di
questo sono sistemiche e correggere la
rotta un lavoro lungo e collettivo
questa è solo la mia goccia nel mare
però per me anche il testimone che
vorrei lasciare alla mia famiglia in
particolare alle mie figlie perché mi
rendo conto oggi che raccontare e
cercare queste storie a un tempo fisico
che tolgo a loro spero però che nel
tempo grazie al tempo grazie all'ascolto
possiamo tessere insieme un filo che
tenga tutto questo insieme e possa dare
voce a più storie possibili
vi ringrazio e vi lascio con una frase
che penso possa riassumere tutto questo
in veramente due righe e ci dice ogni
momento succede due volte fuori e dentro
di noi e queste sono due storie
differenti
grazie mille
[Applauso]